eight news now kind of got you caught up
in the doodle craze but today we are
focusing on a side that many dog owners
tend to ignore that is dog
health yeah christian casadas looking
into the costly aspect of owning a dog
some of the red flags things to watch
out for
and also a very personal journey as well
christian that's right well having a dog
can be fun but any owner can tell you
having a doodle is a lot of work and it
can also be expensive
pet insurance is highly recommended by
any vet my family learned that the hard
way bailey was just a super fun
energetic and loving golden doodle
this was the troublemaker that ruled our
home
bailey was an f1b golden doodle healthy
energetic and made his presence known
everywhere he went
really was a really healthy dog he went
to his routine checkups about checkups
and he you know
always got five stars at his vet
appointment
so he really had no health issues that
we were aware of at the moment but in a
blink of an eye everything changed after
he woke up from a nap
completely tuned out that was a very
long
and sad night it was
extremely difficult because we couldn't
figure out what was wrong with him
he was having walking issues he couldn't
see
more health issues like vomiting and
seizures
after a midnight rush to the emergency
room and several tests
bailey's health spiraled we had no other
choice but to say goodbye
he was still a puppy and that was one of
the hardest things to take in he was
only
a year and two months old and you know
you just never expect to lose a dog so
young i think it's hard for us
as humans not to ever know the answer
veterinarian dr jessica jensen with mbs
pet care says
while most mixed breed dogs are
healthier there are diseases
like hip and bone dysplasia but they are
treatable
insurance for your pet is definitely
very helpful because there's always
going to be
those unexpected emergencies you know
things like that and
unfortunately you know it
it adds up very quickly and it can be
very expensive
jensen says pet insurance is different
than ours there are policies for
emergency care
and others only for preventive care so
it's important
to research bailey had insurance but
what he didn't have
was enough time
well bailey's health insurance did not
cover his expenses because this happened
during the grace period
which would mean he had now a
precondition so that made the vet bill
soar
we never actually found out what caused
this reaction the vet however mentioned
a possible neurological issue
christian gossip is 8 news now